e eu acho que eu que eu gosto de falar
desse assunto de dinheiro porque eu
nunca vi em mesada tem um olhar é
pequenininho eu ia lá na padaria comprar
chocolate eu tinha que ter lavado os
pratos em casa para ganhar meu meu
dinheirinho para comprar o tal do
chocolate invariavelmente eu comprava
que eu sou viciado em doce chocolate mas
eu já sabia que o esforço para ter
comprado aquele chocolate e vinha de um
trabalho que eu tinha realizado então
isso já me desde pequeno meio galgou as
bases ali de finanças pessoais e do
respeito ao ao dinheiro
e aí eu fui trabalhando enfim
empreendendo fui juntando dinheiro e
cheguei na segunda etapa do dinheiro o
que é como investir bem né
e aí nessa época então juntava dinheiro
eu queria lá meu dinheirinho que eu
tinha juntado eu queria investir bem eu
chegava no banco para pedir ajuda aí na
época não me ajudavam e até hoje não
ajuda muito mas enfim aí eu sozinho ia
lá procurar aprender a investir minha
grana para ter mais rentabilidade etc e
fui estudando eu fui lendo fui
aprendendo eu acabei inclusive virando o
guru dos meus amigos para investimentos
então tá lá no churrasco com os amigos a
sobrou uma grana o que que eu faço com
isso a falar contigo daquele nerd que
gosta desse papo de investimentos e
naturalmente tanto que eu gostava eu
acabei entrando no mercado financeiro e
já são os últimos 15 anos trabalhando no
mercado financeiro ajudando as pessoas a
a investir bem mas o meu ponto é eu tive
que aprender sozinho porque a gente não
fala sobre dinheiro em casa a gente não
fala também sobre dinheiro na escola e
um negócio tão importante né eu não
tenho nada contra professores de
geografia mas seria tão bacana tirar com
as matérias de planície planalto e
colocar as finanças pessoais lá para a
criançada vai fazer a diferença gigante
porque dinheiro faz parte do nosso dia a
dia e a gente tem que lidar bem com ele
é mas é porque a gente não fala se ele é
tão importante que a gente eu aprendi
ali da sobre dinheiro ela falar sobre
dinheiro a lidar com dinheiro desde cedo
e eu tenho dois motivos bem matemáticos
mas eu vou entrar antes sem dois mais
filosóficos e eventualmente polêmicos
primeiro religião usa um país católico
maior país católico do mundo ea religião
traz lado seu dna desde a época do
feudalismo leque acumular riqueza não é
um negócio de um legal assim
a gente pode até mencionar sobre
fordismo a budismo prega as pessoas têm
que ser livres e felizes e tal mais tudo
é impermanente
e tirar região do lado vão falar sobre
mídia nós somos o mundo da novela e a
novela tem um poder muito grande de
criar nossa cultura assim como nos
estados unidos aquela máquina de
hollywood consegue entrar na cabeça dos
americanos para criar o american way of
life que você tem que ter uma casa
grande uma garagem para 2 carros uma
cesta de basquete um gramado na frente
no brasil é a novela que faz isso e se
vocês voltarem muitas vezes enredos de
novelas quando vão criar o herói e o
bandido o bandido é sempre o cara que
tem dinheiro ele é normalmente o
empresário a cara do mal que explora as
pessoas e vive uma vida infeliz e o
herói é o cara que vive do bico é o
malandro é o cara que vive um dia após o
outro e ele é o cara feliz então já na
criação ali dos personagens e a gente já
tem uma impressão mas então cuidar
bem do meu dinheiro de dinheiro na hora
gostam legal porque você o bandido da da
história não entendo muito de religião
novela vamos tirar esse para frente vou
mostrar onde eu gosto de falar que a
matemática pra gente tem dois motivos
porque a gente não lida bem com dinheiro
o mais relacionado a finanças pessoais a
planejamento financeiro inflação nossa
somos nós temos uma memória recente de
estabilidade de moeda nós sempre fomos o
país da super inflação até 1993 a
inflação era estratosféricos no brasil
em 1993 a inflação foi de 2.500 por
cento ao ano
e para tornar isso mais palpável essa
maquininha registradora registradora não
re marcador de preços que tá ali ela
chegava marcar os preços uma a duas
vezes por dia dentro do supermercado e
eu vivi a minha infância na década de 80
e início da década de 90 eu mesmo se eu
corresse antes essa maquininha eu
conseguia comprar uma coca-cola 10
porcento mais barato que ela tava lá
sempre remarcando o preço para a gente
tá lá ainda mais palpável o que que é
2500 por cento ao ano imagine que vocês
estão em janeiro de 1993 e vocês querem
comprar um carro o carro da moda na
época pessoal era esse aqui ó escort xr3
se fosse conversível ela ainda mais
fantástico
oi e aí lá em janeiro você juntar uma
grana e você pensar não mas eu vou me
dar esse carro de presente no natal
porque ela me dá esse presente não tava
essa grana toda em vez de comprar o
carro na hora que você botar debaixo do
colchão
e o que vocês compraram em dezembro do
mesmo ano com o mesmo dinheiro que vocês
compraram um carro em janeiro seria só o
tapetinho só o capachinho do carro então
a inflação corroía o poder de compra das
pessoas e esse papo de planejamento a
planilha zinha uma folhinha colada na
geladeira não existia que não existe
estabilidade hoje existe e hoje é
possível planejar e não é construir um
foguete para lua é uma folha de papel
colado na geladeira entradas e saídas já
vai fazer uma diferença gigante na vida
das pessoas hoje na verdade o desafio é
a gente lutar contra esse consumo tão
fácil né e os marqueteiros cada vez mais
habilidosos e a gente tá no trabalho na
frente do notebook e vira para o colega
do lado e diz aí eu tô precisando
comprar um tênis vermelho e aí daqui a
pouco você abre tá grande hein lá no
stories patrocinado instagram promoção
de tênis vermelho e você acha
coincidência o que aconteceu então o
marketing a cada vez mais eficiente e é
tão fácil consumir né porque o cartão de
crédito é digital e tudo aceita eu até
brinco que o cartão de crédito ele tinha
que será que nem cigarro sabe que tem
aquela foto atrás
é a coisa horrível que é consumir
cigarro tem pessoas que não nasceram
para consumir cartão de crédito tem que
ter aquela foto atrás então difícil hoje
é a gente lidar com esse impulso de de
consumir planejar é possível o segundo
ponto é a taxa de juros e ele é muito
mais em cada porque que o brasileiro
investe tão mal o seu dinheiro nós somos
o país da taxa de juros altíssima quem
determina a tal taxa de juros é uma
palavrinha chamada selic que
eventualmente o william bonner lá no
jornal nacional ele falar se ele que
subiu a selic caiu
e a selic é determinada por essa turma
que tá olhando simpaticamente para vocês
uma vez a cada 45 dias eles se reúnem
dizem a taxa de juros vai subir ou a
taxa de juro vai cair que que significa
esse negócio subiu caí uma taxa de juros
para cima significa que o dinheiro está
mais caro na hora que vocês vão foram
comprar a geladeira a parcela dela vai
estar mais cara na hora de fazer o
financiamento da compra do apartamento a
parcela versão mais cara e na hora que
vocês botam o dinheiro de vocês para
remunerar a hora que vocês investem o
dinheiro vocês vão ter mais retorno o
oposto mesmo se a taxa de juros para
baixo a parcela vai ser mais barato o
financiamento apartamento vai ser mais
barato mas na hora que vocês botarem
dinheiro de vocês para render o retorno
vai ser melhor
o nosso sempre devemos taxa de juros
altissimas e aí as pessoas deixavam
dinheiro lá em nos bancos em produtos
ruins e conseguiram mesmo assim tem um
retorno razoável mesmo nos produtos vêm
a boca isso acabou a taxa de juros no
brasil desabou boa aí o quarenta por
cento nos últimos 20 anos foi o 10 por
cento nos últimos três anos ea
expectativa é que ainda mais isso vai
mudar totalmente o o mundo de
investimentos no brasil ea forma como o
brasileiro inverte o brasileiro vai ter
que aprender a investir não dá mais para
deixar o dinheiro e um produto meia-boca
no banco porque senão a pessoa não vai
se aposentar ou não vai realizar o sonho
de empreender ou não vai realizar o
sonho de fazer uma viagem porque os
retornos são menores com taxa de juros
mais baixa mas que bom porque de novo
taxa de juros mais baixos que significa
que o dinheiro está mais barato
significa que a economia vai vai crescer
mas então a gente tem agora a
estabilidade de moeda a gente consegue
planejar a gente tem que taxa de juros
mais baixa que vai ser fantástica para a
economia então
e vamos ver o final de uma forma mais
clara que é óbvio que tem ruído e toda
uma discussão mas hoje o cenário é muito
mais tranquilo no brasil para gente
cuidar bem do dinheiro e aí muitas vezes
eu falo isso sobre cuidar bem do
dinheiro impressas e as pessoas disseram
mas eu não tenho tempo para isso
ah tá mas eu deixo o meu dinheiro lá
parado em que eu não tenho tempo para
cuidar
e não ter tempo para cuidar do dinheiro
significa que vocês não perder ainda
mais dinheiro porque o link do tempo ele
serve para consumo e serve para
investimentos que eu volto para o meu
exemplo lá de comprar um chocolate
e na hora de comprar o chocolate eu
tinha que ter lavado os pratos para
e aí na padaria e comprar outro
chocolate os pratos eram remunerados em
dinheiro mas é verdade alguém eu gostei
tempo para ganhar aquele dinheiro para
consumir o tal do chocolate então o
dinheiro é tempo da nossa vida exemplo
prático tá aí na tela para vocês se uma
pessoa ganha um salário de r$5000
comprar uma coca-cola não custa cinco
reais custa 11 minutos da vida dessa
pessoa se a pessoa ganha r$5000 e quer
comprar essa camiseta do feijão escuro
ela não custa r$250 ela questão de
entrar de trabalho acordou de manhã
pegou o transporte bicicleta e tal foi
trabalho trabalhou a manhã inteira saiu
foi almoçar voltou do almoço foi
trabalhar trabalha outra inteira pegou
transporte foi para casa por causa dessa
camiseta
e eu não estou rezando aqui que a gente
tem que andar maltrapilho e bota um saco
de feijão na cabeça e não não é isso mas
é só para gente ver que o dinheiro que a
gente gasta na verdade dentro de um
tempo que a gente gastou para conseguir
aquele dinheiro então de novo dinheiro a
tempo será que eu quero gastar um dia
inteiro da minha vida por causa dessa
camiseta dos feijões como cada um é
livre para tomar suas decisões mas essa
é uma boa forma de nos ajudar a ter mais
respeito sobre o nosso tempo que a gente
gasta para consumir alguma coisa e o
efeito do tempo ele importante também
que serve também para investimentos por
exemplo se você investir em 20 mil reais
durante quinze anos a poupança cês vão
perder em média 110 mil reais caso tiver
assim investido em melhores produtos de
investimento
o que são 10 110 mil reais transformados
em tempo são 245 mil minutos são mais de
4.000 horas são quase dois anos de
trabalho que vocês perderam
e por investir mal vamos transformar
esse negócio mais palpável de novo se
vocês gostam de esporte seria possível
assistir a todos os jogos de todas as
seleções de todas as copas do mundo duas
vezes com 245 mil minutos
e se você gosta de dar uma caminhada
seria possível fazer todo o caminho de
santiago a pé 22 vezes
e se vocês gostam de séries seria
possível assistir a todos os episódios
de game of thrones 56 vezes eu acho que
vai ser tão legal
é mas seria possível então meu recado é
quando a gente disse que não tem tempo
na verdade a gente perde tempo
o cuidado o dinheiro é bom cuidado
dinheiro não é feio cuidar do dinheiro é
importante se vocês dedicarem um
pouquinho de tempo da vida de vocês para
cuidar melhor do dinheiro vocês vão
gerar mais tempo ainda para gastar em
coisas muito mais legais do que ficar
cuidando do próprio dinheiro obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]